okay
the dance
at the end of time
the dance at the end of time i don't
know if you guys have seen the film
jojo
rabbit it is a
tragic comedy right a film
that makes comedy
in a weird way out of tragedy it takes
place during world war
ii
and
the protagonist undergoes of course a
journey of transformation but i'd like
to talk only about the end of the film
which i think is a testament to what i
think is the dance at the end of time
the end of the film has world war ii
ending and the nazis have been defeated
and our protagonist and
the
his heroine his his girl are now
free they realize that they are now safe
for the first time in their life the war
is over
and
it you know what follows is the
existential question like what do we do
after so much horror after so much
tragedy after so much fear after so much
trauma like like what do we do when the
war is over
and then the girl
responds
you know accordingly
with
what i think is both surprising and also
inevitable what do we do and she starts
going
and then it cuts to the kid and he
starts like doing a little dance and
then it cuts to her and she gets more
into the little dance and so the
response to the existential question is
like what do we do at the end of time
what do we do about death and life what
do we do about war and peace what do we
do with all of our suffering what do we
do with all of our undigested grief we
dance we dance the dance at the end of
time
is exactly what we do the the pathway to
heaven
is
is dance you know it's like my friend
louise he said you know when i die and i
find out that there is eternal life that
heaven is real
i will literally walk into that space
dancing like the character in jojo
rabbit and so it was a very um astute
and beautiful observation because in
truth
life is tragic um but it's also magic
and and i think so many of us get caught
in in what to do about the tragedy right
how do we respond to the existential
weight of our condition how do we
respond to our fear to our trauma to our
grief jamie weil says we're all choking
on undigested
grief and i think the
that you know art can offer a pathway to
redemption by saying that perhaps we
hang ourselves willingly on the cross
but you know what happens when we
finally surrender when we finally hang
ourselves on the cross we realize the
nails are no longer there they disappear
and we're no longer dead we're actually
brought back to life and this
revivification makes us twice born and
through dance we become twice born and
so that's what i wanted to share the
power of dance at the end of time this
is the pathway to salvation we lose our
sense of separateness and temples of
fragmentation in the form of electronic
buddhism as alan harrington wrote and
like the film jojo rabbit ends to the to
the music of david bowie
um
we feel it we know it
we become it
dan da da da
and